bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono famigie oggi siamo
sul set john simulator quindi raga io
per oggi sono dottor fa vj e direi che
possiamo cominciare con l'operazione
sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
aspiranti dottori siamo qui per imparare
oggi dottor fa vj vi insegnerà ad
esportare un cuore e a rimpiazzarlo
quindi oggi andremo ad eseguire un
trapianto di cuore allora ragazzi la
prima cosa che si deve fare in questi
casi è quella di rimuovere rimuovere
utilizziamo i metodi adatti rimuovere la
parte superiore del nostro paziente che
ostruisce non serve un cazzo perfetto
una volta fatto questo bisogna anche
togliere la radio che fa un casino della
madonna e non serve a niente
una volta arrivati a questo punto
l'operazione è semplice si divide in
diverse fasi iniziamo con la prima molto
importante la prima fase durante un e
sport l'esportazione di un cuore è
quella di rimuovere la parte in
superficie ovvero la cassa toracica e
per farla si utilizzano gli attrezzi
adatti ovvero il primo attrezzo che
andremo ad utilizzare oggi e il martello
una volta impugnato saldamente il
martello va utilizzato con molta molta
cautela e con esso andremo a rimuovere
la parte superiore del nostro paziente
molto ma molto delicatamente andiamo a
ritmo esatto perfetto una volta rimossa
la suddetta parte bisogna accertarsi che
il nostro paziente effettivamente non è
conscio di quello che stiamo per andare
a fare è per per verificare se il
paziente effettivamente è conscio
bisogna provare a mandarlo a quel paese
se vedete che il paziente non risponde a
questa provocazione molto probabilmente
è ancora privo di coscienza e quindi si
può passare alla fase numero due la fase
numero due
durante l'esportazione di un cuore è
quella di rimuovere gli organi
in eccesso ovvero quelli che sono stati
prima rimossi con il martello molto ma
molto delicatamente per rimuoverli si
può utilizzare tranquillamente il palmo
della mano e bisogna appoggiarli
delicatamente su un ripiano adeguato una
volta fatto diciamo se questi sono gli
organi che non ci interessano durante
l'operazione e quindi essendo soltanto
due polmoni possiamo tranquillamente non
utilizzarli perché non servono perfetto
una volta fatto questo bisogna sempre
rimuovere anche le parti in eccesso
perché ovviamente le ossa possono
rimanere all'interno del nostro paziente
quindi bisogna occuparsi di rimuovere
anch'esse perfetto
bisogna afferrare molto ma molto
saldamente per non far accorgere
paziente di quello che sta succedendo
perché ovviamente il paziente deve
dormire sogni tranquilli e svegliarsi
molto ma molto ma molto tranquillizzato
rispetto a prima
quindi appunto molto delicatamente
prestiamoci elevare le parti in eccesso
no questa non è volata [ __ ] ok
utilizzate sempre dei linguaggi molto
professionali anche per nel rispetto del
vostro team che vi sta aiutando durante
l'operazione perché se stesse di cassano
messo tutta sta roba sul banco mitja che
quando lavoro io ho detto che non voglio
casini sul banco vabbè comunque
tutta colpa del team proseguiamo c'è un
pezzo non identificato che non sappiamo
che cos'è ma nel caso non sapete che
cos'è un qualcosa voi non toccatela è
proseguita senza allora prima di
rimuovere il cuore e giustamente è
d'obbligo recidere i collegamenti di
gomma che collegano il cuore alla cassa
toracica interna e quindi per farlo
bisogna utilizzare anche qui gli
attrezzi adatti in teoria per rimuovere
queste piccolissime questi tubicini di
gomma bisogna utilizzare l'attrezzo
molto ma molto piccolo quindi in questo
caso andremo a scegliere il seghetti
know piccolino piccolino e con esso
andremo a rimuovere
diciamo queste addio nel carnet il caso
nel caso siate per sbaglio la faccia del
paziente con una sega enorme
se il paziente non si muove vuol dire
che potete continuare tranquilli perché
non si è incavolato comunque ricordate
di afferrarlo molto ma molto saldamente
e una volta fatto si può proseguire a
recidere le parti interessate perfetto
no diciamo è un po difficile all'inizio
perché diciamo tutti alle prime armi
potrebbe sbagliare però all'inizio
bisogna recidere le parti ok
bisogna bisogno bisogna recidere le
parti di golf no se per se ok ok
una è andata ragazzi un'andata è andato
anche l'altra manca l'ultima manca
l'ultima manca l'ultima macca l'ultima
perfetto una volta decisa anche l'ultima
parte psi si appresta a rimuovere il
cuore molto delicatamente con il palmo
della mano
quindi inseriamo la mano all'interno e
rimuoviamo il cuore porc cioè di quella
frutta è una volta che si rimuove il
cuore bene se per caso vostro paziente
ha mangiato di recente dell'attak e
quindi gli organi interni non non sono
rimossi molto facilmente
bisogna utilizzare degli attrezzi
appositi per aiutarsi quindi in questo
caso può tornare utile il nostro amico
martello nostra vico martello sempre
molto delicatamente ci si appresta a
rimuovere l'organo interessato molto
delicatamente molto delicatamente molto
porca [ __ ]
ok perfetto bisogna bisogna bisogna
effetto star wars trans devo portare
piede di porco
ok
è una volta che non si riesca ma nel
caso vi cade il martello all'interno del
vostro paziente
ricordatevi di nasconderlo con qualche
oggetto in modo che il paziente non si
accorga di quello che è successo
bene
mi è arrivato anche un messaggio quindi
mi scusi signor paziente ma se il
paziente non se ne accorge voi potete
tranquillamente rispondere perché tanto
non penso si arrabbi vodafone si beh ok
va bene diciamo che il primo intervento
della giornata in genere è quello di
allenamento quindi l'intervento numero 2
invece è l'intervento definitivo appunto
perché il primo è un po per diciamo
sgranchirsi le ossa quindi è anche
giusto fare degli errori all'inizio si
possono tranquillamente fare quindi per
il secondo paziente apprestiamoci come
sempre a rimuovere da parte superiore
dopodiché anche la radio se ci fosse una
canzone di j ax
ma evidentemente non c'è manco quella se
si incastra radio sperate che il
paziente abbia dei tappi alle orecchie
perché se la musica inascoltabile
comunque nel caso per tentare di
spingere giù ulteriormente la radio
provate a lanciare qualcos'altro
se si incastra anche quello ma andate
tutti affanculo eh va beh questa volta
per rimuovere la parte superiore del
nostro paziente
bisogna utilizzare un altro attrezzo
perché altresì ovviamente possono
variare quindi afferriamo saldamente
porca [ __ ] psicosi che non serve a
niente afferriamo saldamente la sega
automatica prima che cada perfetto una
volta afferrata molto ma molto
delicatamente girarla a 90 gradi
perfetto e una volta fatto a prestarsi a
rimuovere la parte superiore come in
precedenza molto ma molto delicatamente
in modo che il paziente non si accorga
di quello che sta succedendo perfetto
una volta effettuata questa operazione
appoggiare
lo strumento utilizzato e se sì cazzo
bene ma è un vantaggio questo perché la
musica che sta scontando fa talmente
schifo che nelle taglierei anch'io le
orecchie comunque se per caso vi cade
una sega automatica sull'orecchio del
paziente
ass auguratevi che sia ascoltando musica
di merda così la meno diciamo sarà
soltanto un sollievo come prima ci si
appresta a rimuovere le parti inutili
ovvero gli organi in eccesso e tutte le
ossa che non comunemente non servono un
cazzo wingardium leviosa vabbè comunque
una volta rimosse
ok per fece anche la forte no ok
perfetto c'è anche la forbice che non
avevo notato quindi si può prendere
anche la forbice o cazzo cazzo non
morire
[Musica]
ok ragazzi il terzo paziente della
giornata una volta finiti gli
allenamenti e quello definitivo
quindi quando si passa a eseguire la
vera operazione bisogna essere molto
serie quindi si passa sì ci si appresta
inizialmente a rimuovere la parte
superiore che è inutile che copre tutto
quanto dopodichè la musica come al
solito va rimossa perfetto ok
pensavo che si incastrasse anche questa
volta ma evidentemente ha avuto pietà di
noi
bene bisogna portare al termine almeno
un'operazione al giorno perché sennò il
paziente si potrebbe giustamente
incazzare quindi apprestiamoci a
prendere il martello per rimuovere
velocemente la parte superiore come al
solito ovviamente dovreste riuscire a
centrare almeno le ossa perché sennò è
un po difficile
ok colmani conoco la parte davanti
dovremmo riuscire a ok perfetto una
volta utilizzato il martello di thor con
molta delicatezza come sempre
allontaniamo tutti i pezzi residui ok
perfetto
ok una volta allontanati sto pezzo
enorme va bene può andare anche in fondo
non importa è incredibilmente siamo
arrivati al cuore
i cinque secondi perfetto come sempre
una volta rimossi tutti i pezzi bisogna
sempre questa è una cosa molto
importante ricordarsi di ad accertarsi
se il paziente è sveglio comunque
ricapitolando una volta arrivati al
cuore come sempre bisogna agire con
molta delicatezza e eliminare e dei
tubicini di gomma ok perfetto la
cartellina non serve un cazzo perfetto
la no no bisogna no bisogna impugnarla
in modo molto saldo perché se no non si
può tranquilla non si può fare
un'operazione seria una volta impugnata
in modo saldo come come prima bisogna
recidere ok la prima parte andata
mancano le altre due parti con molta
delicatezza molta delicatezza molta
delicatezza
ok perfetto e una volta arrivati a
questo punto come sempre bisogna
rimuovere il cuore
sperando che si tolga
madonna
bene ok evidentemente non si stacca
[Musica]
va bene ci sono delle situazioni
anormali ma sono del tutto comuni in
questo campo diciamo nel caso il cuore
non si stacca possiamo provare a niente
inserire il secondo cuore però
ricordatevi di farlo sempre con molta
delicatezza
una volta inserito il secondo cuore
all'interno bisogna occuparsi di
rimettere le ossa precedentemente
rimosse perché se no il nostro paziente
ovviamente non può vivere quindi perché
le ossa appunto servono per proteggere
il cuore quindi se noi inseriamo il
quale ma non inseriamo giustamente le
ossa
mi spiegate come fa migliore paziente
non può quindi assicuriamoci di inserire
il cuore poi se ne ha due almeno se se
ne rompe uno l'altro di scorta quindi
magari due cuori du corps is meglio che
one quindi infiliamo dentro tutto è
possibile
e dopo di che inseriamo le ossa se
volete provare a fare un paio di tiri a
canestro per allenarvi della partita del
pomeriggio
potete tranquillamente farlo con le ossa
comunque ricordate perfetto i cotton
fioc i cotton fioc sono essenziali in
questa operazione perché ci aiutano ad
abbellire l'interno del nostro paziente
anzi facciamo proprio così proviamo a
una penna una penna se volete firmare il
cuore perché ovviamente quando paziente
andrà in giro e tutti si chiederanno ma
chi è che mi ha dato questo cuore
fantastico almeno lasciando la vostra
firma sul cuore potrete
diciamo firmarmi e farmi pubblicità
quindi non è illegale firmare il cuore
perfetto
una volta fatto se volete se vi sentite
in vena di scherzare potete disegnare
anche i baffi in modo che poi quando il
paziente si svegli lo prendano un pò in
giro perché ovviamente fa bene ridere
dopo queste operazioni comunque si può
tranquillamente inserire il cotton fioc
all'interno perché controfiocchi
ricordiamo che aiuta a pulire aiuto a
pulire oltre all'interno delle orecchie
anche l'interno dello stomaco
però se il cotton fioc e non riuscito a
metterlo vanno bene anche
tranquillamente degli attrezzi presi sul
momento
ricordate le ossa vanno messe tutte
quante serene dimenticate qualcuno
perché è caduta
vabbè tanto bassa che non fate accorgere
paziente di quello che è successo è ed è
tutto a posto
ovviamente per dare un tocco di colore
visto che c'è del viola del rosso ma
anche al verde mancherebbe anche il blu
però va bene finché c'è il verde va bene
allora il cui tocco di colore in più c'è
fatto questo direi che abbiamo finito e
il paziente è pronto a rimettersi in
piedi
allora ragazzi una volta finite le
operazioni del giorno potete
tranquillamente prendermi una pausa è
perfetto sta roba mi stava letteralmente
uccidendo va bene raga
direi che il mio dovere da dottore qui è
finito dottor house modestamente mi fa
una pippa e niente come al solito se
video vi è piaciuto ed è stato
istruttivo
lasciate un commento qui sotto mi piace
anche la pagina facebook che come al
solito trovate nella descrizione di ogni
mio video se non siete ancora iscritti
scrivetemi e ci vediamo un prossimo
video bella ragazzi